this is something that people tend to
avoid because it's
it's painful yeah um but but
i think this is a very common mistake so
when i
figured that out i went whoa
i changed everything i did on my show
customers are very smart you should
never underestimate customers
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
i believe hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something greater inside you two you've
got
michael jordan level talent at something
so today let's live your best believe
life
and learn the seven best lessons from
elon musk warren buffett and other
billionaires
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one look for negative feedback with elon
musk
it's very important to to seek out uh to
actively seek out
um and listen very carefully to negative
feedback
and this is something that people tend
to avoid because it's
it's painful yeah um but but
i think this is a very common mistake is
to to not
actively seek out and listen to
uh negative feedback what do you do that
you go into forums do you go into
twitter like what are your
areas where you go to look for feedback
on let's say the tesla well
it's like everyone i talk to is um in
fact when um
when friends get a product i say look i
don't tell me what you like
tell me what you don't like right um and
and because
otherwise your friend is not going to
tell you what he doesn't like right this
girl's going to say oh i love this and
that and
and then and leave out the this is the
stuff i don't like list
because too much of your friend want you
know it doesn't want to
offend you so um
so you really need to
[Music]
to to to to sort of coax negative
feedback
and you should you know that if somebody
is your is your friend or at least
not your enemy and they're giving you
negative feedback um
then they may be wrong but it's coming
from a good place
um and sometimes even your enemies give
you good negative feedback
rule number two be clear about your
intention with oprah winfrey
everything you try to do is already done
so when i figured that out oh what i'm
putting
out is what's coming back let me get
real clear about what it is
i'm putting out real clear so
i read a book about 1989 called seed of
the soul
and in that book gary zhukov talked
about the laws
of karma of the laws
of cause and effect the third law of
motion
and in that book he talked about how
intention your intention is
always one
with the law meaning before you even
think about a thing
you have an intention for the thing and
that the intention
is going to determine the outcome
that's why the same people can go to the
same church service
and somebody walked down the aisle just
to be seen
to put some money in the
church and somebody else who just goes
and just has a little bit to offer
the intention with which you give
the intention with which you serve
determines the outcome so when i figured
that out i went whoa
i changed everything i did on my show
i called in the producers and i said
from this day
forward i will no longer be speaking to
the kkk
i will no longer be speaking to people
who are fighting each other in a way
that it is damaging to the character of
myself and other people who watch
from this day forward i am only going to
do
intentional television rule number three
focus on
passion with warren buffett the question
is about the personal quality we look
for in the in the executives we place at
our various companies
the first thing is we don't usually
place them i mean they come with them uh
we don't have anybody to place so i have
the problem occasionally if somebody
dies or
uh to replace a a ceo
but most of our ceos came with the deal
clayton homes which we're buying comes
with kevin clayton right
running it we will put no one in there
he will run the place just as before
but in terms of the personal quality
when when a
seller comes to me with a business
whether it's clayton or any of those and
the others ike friedman at borsheim's
mrs b
at nebraska furniture mark when they
come to me the first question i have to
ask myself because i'm counting on them
to run the place
i have to decide what do they love the
money or do they love the business
now there's nothing wrong with liking
the money i mean they all like money but
but they've got to love the business
they got to have a passion for it
because if i give them a whole bunch of
money and they love the money and they
don't love the business
no matter what they tell me six months
from now they'll be gone you know i mean
they'll just all of a sudden say why am
i getting up at seven in the morning
just so i can send a lot of money to
omaha you know i mean it
it just it won't work so they have to
love the business i mean i want people
with a passion for the business
i used to say that i had a one-line
employment form
one question employment form the
question was are you a fanatic
you know if you answered yes you got the
job because i want somebody's fanatic
about their business also if you want to
have more confidence and learn from
billionaires daily
check out my 254 series they're free the
links to join are in the description
below
there are just times when something is
important enough
you believe in it enough that you you do
it in spite of fear
they made us all these crazy things to
get out of ourselves and so we stood on
tables and did all kinds of things they
think
that success is supposed to happen like
that
rule number four learn from your
mistakes with mark zuckerberg
no matter what you do you're gonna make
a ton of mistakes
right and i made it every mistake i
think you can probably make i mean
mistakes on how to set up the company
mistakes in hiring product mistakes
technical mistakes
anything you can you can kind of think
about doing wrong
um i have probably made that mistake um
in in trying to kind of build facebook
up right i mean and it kind of makes
i was a college student when i got
started right i mean i didn't know
anything about business
or hiring you know no one is born with
these skills right so
you learn them the same way that you
learn uh everything else right trial and
error
you do it uh you don't be too afraid to
make mistakes and
you do make mistakes and you recover and
you keep going
the the thing that i think is really
what you should focus on
is not what is the mistake that you
should avoid
but instead if you do something
good you get the strength to power
through a lot of mistakes
rule number five use the scientific
framework of thinking with bill gates
i think the the quality that uh
has helped me in lots of things is
a kind of measurement scientific
framework where i go in and say did
anybody handle this well
what are the very best practices do we
have numbers on that
and let's get everybody measuring what
they're doing
and so they can strive to match
what that the best achievement is for us
often that's something like getting the
vaccines out to all the children
some very poor countries uh do that
extremely well because they get down to
that local level and measure the
activity they make sure the inventory's
there they make sure the workers are
showing up
so for me i always look at how can we do
better
better measurement and use that to drive
the very best practices rule number six
earn trust with jeff bezos
one of the reasons we have been able to
extend into new business areas and
first new product categories going way
back we just sold books and then we
started playing music and
dvds and electronics and toys and so on
and then we've extended into electronic
reading with kindle
the reason customers have been receptive
in large part to our new initiatives
is because we have worked hard to earn
trust with them
earning trust with customers is
is a valuable business asset and if you
uh mistreat their data they will
know they will figure it out customers
are very smart you should never
underestimate customers
and rule number seven the last one
before very special bonus clip
is don't plan
[Music]
now i've got a special bonus clip with
mark cuban on how to be
different that i think you're going to
enjoy but before that it's time for the
question of the day
i want to know where do you need to stop
planning so much let me know put it down
in the comments below and if you made it
this far in a video you're still here
watching and you promise you commit to
yourself that you're gonna take
action we don't just watch videos here
believe nation we do something about it
give me a hashtag believe down the
comments below if that's you
so i can celebrate with you too you
talked about companies having a
unique advantage can you speak more on
that for me please sure i mean
what is it that that a customer can get
from you
that they can't get from anybody else
and you have to be very careful with
that too when i just talked about lying
to yourself as an entrepreneur
because often we'll say well it's just
like uber
but it has pink cars uber doesn't have
pink cars
that that's a difference without a
distinction right
lots of times people get confused
between what's a product and what's a
feature
pink uber cars that's a feature that's
not a unique product
excuse me so you have to know what it is
that you do
that is so unique people's the people
your potential customers say whoa
i did not know that as opposed to well
let me go tell
uber that they should probably add pink
cars
because whenever you're competing with
them you know all of you are going to
compete with amazon at some point
if you're not already just the reality
and so you've got to understand when
amazon starts looking at my customer
base
what is it that i can convey to them
that makes me unique
and that's that's what i meant by unique
difference
[Music]
if you want more lessons from
billionaire entrepreneurs check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there you know i worked weekends i
didn't believe in vacation
and so i i really pushed people to work
hard
have you ever met a person who was a
great reader when they were young who
was not successful